pas un bus n'a quitté le dépôt de
vaux-le-pénil depuis maintenant plus de
quinze jours aucun service n'est assuré
les salariés vont entamer leur septième
semaine de grève en cause une
réorganisation de leur emploi du temps
qui selon eux et allongent le temps de
travail avant on avait 100% de temps de
travail effectif sur notre oeil de serre
liste maintenant les battements et les
coupures il nous met entend indemniser
ce qui change c'est que voulait d'avoir
des semaines à 35 heures on avait une
modulation 34,36 de moyenne 35 là on va
se retrouver sur de 39 40 42 heures pour
essayer d'avoir 35 heures de tp au
travail effectif les salaires sont bien
conservées sur les temps d'y indemnisés
mais les salariés dénoncent une
réduction de leurs salaires liée à
l'allongement du temps de travail bah
comment il a des grandes amplitudes on
passe plus de temps au travail mais on
n'est pas rémunéré en conséquence parce
que au tout début le t il était rémunéré
à 50% le temps et des musées et du coup
on avait une perte de salaire maintenant
ils ont proposé à 100% mais le problème
c'est que ils nous font des semaines à
33 heures et lui nous prennent du pays
pour compenser cette perte et du coup on
se retrouve toujours dans le même délire
quoi c'est à dire bah d'un côté vous
d'elle de votre côté vous enlève de son
côté la direction avance que les
négociations sont toujours en cours si
la plupart des dépôts restent en grève
est celui de lieusaint à quelques
kilomètres de vaux-le-pénil à lui repris
le travail samedi dernier le mouvement
qui en ce moment gagne plus en plus de
terrain c'est le cas à reims mais aussi
en bretagne